[Musique]
pour ce premier numéro 2 tous à table
nous avons eu beaucoup de mal à choisir
parmi les dizaines et les dizaines de
cartes postales que vous nous avez
envoyées mais il fallait faire un choix
et le mardi 1er décembre
nous venions tournée a beau mode obertan
en haute saône
c'est donc ici à abobo obertan chez
madame germaine genro que nous avons
passé ce petit quart d'heure de cette
première émission tous à table
germaine syndrome bonjour vous allez
mener deux de vos meilleures recettes
qui sont les quarts dans la moelle vous
êtes en train de riom commencé à
éplucher les gardons et le gigot
surprise alors on va commencer avec le
cardan à la moelle comment vous le
faites on prend un quart dans les
peluches ou non leur a volé les piquants
parce qu'elle est piquant les peluches
comme il faut parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
deux fils et en mai trempe et à mesure
dans de l'eau vinaigrée pour qu'ils
noircissent pas ensuite on fait bouillir
à l'eau salée oui une heure et demi ici
c'est une personne originaire et 50
minutes si c'est une cocotte-minute
ensuite on les gouttes et ont fait un
roux avec eux mais on met chauffer de
l'huile dont jean leroux donc dans une
casserole rôle dans une cocotte
on met de l'huile un peu d'un d'eisai
8 5 8 gousses d'ail j'ai coupé un si
gros on les fait revenir on fait on
ajoute deux grosses cuillères de farine
ou trois selon la quantité et ont fait
dorer ensuite on ajoute du bouillon ou
de l'eau avec un bouillon cube et
ensuite tout ça vous mettez ça dans un
plat le cardon n'est une couche de
cardons une couche de juillet et quand
quand le plat et est plein on verse le
roux dessus et on prend la moelle d'un
os à moelle
on la met dessus et au four donc ces
quantités en fait gratuit 2009 you le
four lions peut-être plus le four
préchauffé à à 200
et c'est pour pour commettre personnes
cette recette pour 4 personnes
s'aperçoit qu'un quart dans ça dépend un
beau gars dont un beau car dans cinq six
personnes à bord dont cinq super soirée
facile facilement et alors pendant que
les gardant au chaud dans le four madame
châtearoux je vous propose de rejoindre
tout de suite bruno gâteau qui notre
chef et qui va nous donner quelques
trucs par exemple comment bien réussir
une mayonnaise qui n'est pas facile pas
évident et puis tout de suite après il
nous donnera sa recette une petite
recette facile et pas chère qui
s'appelle le chou d'escargots au
cerfeuil
alors on rejoint tout de suite bruno
gâteau premier truc bruno la mayonnaise
comment réussir une bonne mayonnaise ce
qui n'est pas évident oui la mayonnaise
ccsa bleu mais il faut tout de même
prendre certaines précautions surtout
une question de température souvent 1
donc il faut que l'on prenne la
précaution de sortir et préparer le
thunder sortie du frigidaire un peu al
avance de veiller à la température de
lui car souvent ça vient de ce fait
lorsque nous manque la mayonnaise
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas veillé à cette
température sur les 1 puis peut-être
l'histoire du sel que l'on doit ne pas
laisser sur les jaunes sans remuer je
pense que à partir de là en fait tous et
bonne mayonnaise deuxième truc la
vinaigrette
comment rattraper une vinaigrette aux
illuminés great c'est aussi un petit
truc simple en prenant un peu d'eau
douce un récipient séparés et en
reversant progressivement ou à la louche
ou à la cuillère et en remuant
on s'aperçoit que 7 à 7 cet apport d'eau
douce relie la mayonnaise et au besoin
en bout de la saison devance la folie la
saugrenue la vinaigrette pardon
[Musique]
pour cette recette il faut de la pâte à
choux du cerfeuil des escargots du
beurre d'escargot de la salade et puis
de quoi l'assaisonner l'idéal serait
d'utiliser du vinaigre de xérès et de
l'huile de pépins de raisin mais un gie
[ __ ] et 8 courant peuvent parfaitement
convenir
oh
alors rapidement bruno peut-on rappeler
comment on fait cette pâte à choux oui
c'est très simple lorsqu'on a fait
bouillir l'eau le sel le beurre qui est
fondu on a préalablement tamiser la
farine on incorpore cette farine et on
donne un peu de corps à la panade
obtenus sur le feu pendant quelques une
minute dix ans on ressort du feu en
incorpore anna les cinq heures que vous
avez vu préparer et la pâte à choux est
prête c'est donc très simple
donc nous allons dresser sur plaque les
choux c'est ce que je vais faire
alors une petite première partie pour
faire le pied ensuite le cerfeuil
jean-pierre en est le cerfeuil là et
ensuite on complète on fait un show
assez gros à la poche
on va le doré maintenant c'est doré et
le passé au four la dorure cette arnaque
qui a été battu avec une toute petite
pointe de sel on utilise un passe aussi
pour le répartir dessus
[Applaudissements]
pendant que les choux cuisent il faut 20
minutes environ on fait revenir les
escargots à la poêle les escargots sont
un point quand on commence à sentir live
une opération qui prend de 7 à 8 minutes
[Musique]
voici donc les choux qui s'enfuit
maintenant sont assez sec
nous allons les évider l'enfant dans son
show télé d'un torchon et nous allons
découper le fond voici un an jean-pierre
dégarnir 9 10 12 escargots dedans et on
va simplement remettre le couvercle en
quelque sorte le fond et je dispose est
bien au centre de quelques feuilles de
salade qui peuvent être de la laitue qui
vous fait une salade de saison que nous
avons à assaisonner avec un vinaigres
fins de l'huile de pépins de raisin qui
est plus légère et on peut également
pardon jean-pierre clocher montagnes
rocheuses et servir et nous vous
souhaitons pas l'appétit
voilà alors sans transition derrière là
la recette du chou escargots haussière
feuilles votre recette madame chabot le
gigot surprise on dit pas qu'on dit pas
tout de suite pourquoi ces surprises
mais on dira après comme à sainte
hermine et alors on y va
alors on prend un gigot d'agneau un beau
gigot de 2 kg et avec quelques mots ont
le même arrivé avec un litre de
beaujolais ou de bourgogne les eaux
écrasée de carottes coupées en gros
morceau un oignon 2
gousse d'ail 1 bouquet garni 1 2000 et 6
litres de vinaigre et 2 cuillerées
d'huile et on met un mais marine et
trois jours faisant trop juin dans trois
jours on le tourne tous les jours pour
qu'ils prêtent bien le bienvenu parce
que la marina ne couvre pas une fois que
le gigot est prêt maintenant nous allons
voir la préparation de la sauce de ce
gie gossio prime dès lors comment s'y
prend-on alors on met de l'huile dans
une casserole sens il faut coke dans une
fois mais la marinade 4 lui les shows
dont mais la marinade à guillet
[Musique]
ça fait des prêts dans bien dorés on
ajoute de la farine ont fait dorer
encore doré pas falloir pas vous laisser
dorer
quand la farine et dorée on ajoute à la
tomate le restant de la marinade le jus
de la marinade paris 102 le vinaigre le
reste en guinée c'est à dire encore à
radio et un bon niveau de vie de suisse
2011 des lignes et un demi litre de
bouillon gras ou al islami litres d'eau
avec un fil et on fait bouillir ça
pendant une heure à petit peu là les
quads et or fait ça c'est important de
dire quand c'est bouillie pas à l'
impasse tout à la passoire très fine on
remet cuisent que pour que ça se
réduisent à demi nue et la sauce est
prête et la sonitra essentielle pour
accompagner le dos pendant que les
gigots cuit normalement comme un gigot
je vous propose de suivre notre rubrique
suivante le dictionnaire des termes de
cuisine appareil un appareil est une
partie d'une recette en général
lorsqu'on dit mélangé à l'appareil telle
ou telle autre partie pour terminer une
recette ce terme peut paraître curieux
surprenant lorsqu'on remplit sur une
recette mais en fait c'est une partie de
la recette bouquet garni bouquet garni
c'est des queues de persil du thym du
laurier que l'on ficelles et que l'on
prépare en quantité par rapport à une
recette que l'on met dans une recette
par une cuisson braisé braisé alors on
breizh plus spécialement des bas
morceaux qui devront fuir plus
longuement et a couvert au four avec un
mouvement cours
brunoise c'est une petite mirepoix est
un peu la taille de coupe que l'on fait
pour voir une salade russe petites
carottes petits serrée et s'est coupé en
dés petit silence religieux
voilà donc le gigot surprise lorsqu'on
dit madame joindront à ce qu'on dit
pourquoi on n'a pas le soir un gigot
surprise pour beaucoup il possède
cependant je vous donnais en commun
voilà ces craintes en gouttes première
la surprise aujourd'hui par leur mérite
qu'on le dit pas paris la surprise après
l'invasion vous aimez bien sûr la
cuisine oui bon vous passez combien
d'heures par jour dans votre cuisine
ça dépend de la 3do trois heures oui au
moins m'écoutais je vous remercie de
votre accueil et puis je donne rendez
vous à tous ceux qui nous regardent au
mercredi 13 janvier pour un prochain
numéro 2 tous à table
et n'oubliez pas que nous avons besoin
de vous pour réaliser cette émission
comme aujourd'hui avec madame gindreau
alors vous nous écrivez vous nous
envoyez votre set sur une carte postale
à l'adresse suivante
m
[Musique]